with sheffield though they're
facing a pitcher who's probably at the
the top of his game at least based on
his short
big league career he's not a pitcher who
necessarily lives with a fastball at the
top of the zone his sinker and slider
combo
is what he rides with swinging a miss
for strike three
the heater gets solac and it's one up
one down
three one pitch and that one on the
ground and right through
into left field frazier is on with a two
out single
they have the shift on form sheffield's
pitch swung on fly ball
and a right center field over is fraley
to his right lewis to his left kyle
takes over and lewis will make the catch
for out number three
no runs ahead they go up against jordan
lyles the right-hander for the texas
rangers here this evening
in seattle jordan keeps the hands in
close to the chest in his wind he throws
a curve and it's swung on and missed and
down goes crawford well now two on for
kyle seeger
first pitch that'll get it done
[Applause]
in front of the track makes the catch
hagerty can waltz home
kyle seeger a sac fly out to center
field the mariners in front early one
nothing
and here is first baseman evan white
good to see the kid back in the lineup
the 3-2
hard hit past frazier into left field
here comes another pair
lewis's and nola is right behind him as
evan white
stings a double into the corner and it's
three nothing mariners
two and two there's a breaking ball
grounded on the
outfield grass to rookie he flips onto
first and the size retired
and rangers have something cooking here
in the top of the third men of the
corners one out and danny santana coming
up
1-1 swinging a ball hit high and deep to
left center field that sends hagerty
back on the run he reaches up and makes
the catch
red snyder tags from third he scores so
it's a sac fly for danny but
todd fraser 3-0 count sheffield set and
comes to the plate swung on
and pop to left field medium left field
here comes
hagerty coming in and makes a one hand
catch and that'll do it
for the rangers they get one here come
the mariners again
and another guy swinging a pretty good
bat is austin nola
up the middle over the bag and into
center field kyle lewis is being waved
in
he scores standing the maritals now lead
it four to one
evan white to it a two run double in the
first swing on driven deep to left
that big time carrying there it goes a
home run
three-run jack by evan white and the
mariners have blown it open
7-1 here against texas he's got five
rbis tonight
19 on the season basement kyle sagers
playing
shortstop with a shift on the wind-up
and the o2 pitch
check swing strike three call sheffield
gets them looking
here's the stretch and the two-two pitch
swing and a miss at a fastball first
strike three another strikeout for
justice sheffield that's number three
here's the stretch and now the one-two
pitch the rep snyder
swing and a miss and a breaking ball
down and in for strike three
justice sheffield strikes out the side
here in the top of the fourth inning he
has four strikeouts along the way
begins the year with a four-game hitting
streak this is only his fourth game
since coming up from
tacoma 2-2 and that one's shot to left
field
diving for it so lack he comes up with
it fully spread out heading towards the
line he takes a hit away from
sam hagerty that's a nice play there by
nick solak on a sinking liner
the 1-2 swing in a line drive down the
left field a fair ball three-hit night
for kyle lewis
he's digging for second he'll make it
easily solace up with the ball the throw
to third
kyle lewis in at second base standing up
with a double
his third hit tonight so taylor hearn
now will be the man
in charge of stopping evan white to lead
off cut on a miss fastball at 96.
so he whiffs his first batter here's a
2-2
swing and a miss down goes frayley so
hearn fans the first two batters he
faces base and joey gallo
struck him out on a slider looking as
last time up cut
on and missed slider gets him again
fifth strikeout for sheffield
two on two outs ref schneider batch and
the pitch
swung on and driven deep to left hagerty
going towards the gap in left center
field he's got room
heels on the track makes the catch top
of the sixth is over mariners have two
one
tim lopes oh for three with an rbi
groundout
for the corner and it is a fair ball
hops over the fence or ground rule
double
that's good for [ __ ] yeah that's what he
needed right there that brings home nola
on his birthday no less oh there you go
and now the mariners have the bases
loaded with one out here's the stretch
now the 2-1 pitch swung on ground ball
up the top
over the top of the mountain to the
second baseman odor backhands tossed
back to the shortstop
at second for the force and the mariners
now lead the rangers
10-1 what six rbi tonight for evan white
right-hander yoshihisa hirano getting
ready to make his mariners debut
here's the stretch and the 2-1 on the
way to santana swinging a pop-up
shallow left field toward the line over
seeger in the foul territory kyle is
there he makes the catch and the ball
game is over the mariners win it big